はい では今日のテーマの内容を説明することになります
えーと これはもうとてつもない難しいテーマなんです
で あの 我々はインターネットでも出してあったような感じで
やっぱり何かそれについて喋ると思うと
やっぱり頭がパニック状態に陥っちゃうんです
どこから喋ればいいか
どこまで喋ればいいか
どんなレベルにするか
もう取り留めのない大変なポイントなんです
ですから 皆様はこの世界で全ての宗教
哲学 概念 考え あれこれ何見ても
それ何よりも優れている
人間の生き方を示す 人間が生きるべき道を示す
この慈悲の瞑想は気持ちよく実践しましたから
まあこれすごい力のある瞑想なんです
だから今日はあの 2010年のね
最初の講演でもありますからね
新年の挨拶もしなくちゃいけないし
ですから 皆様にはこのご一緒に慈悲の瞑想をできたことでね
もう最大な幸福が訪れると思います
真面目に思っています
お世辞ではなくて で これは証拠は全部証拠済みなんです
慈悲の瞑想をすると もの見事に人生は好転していくんです
どんな問題も解決して
とても薄々ね 水が流れるように
風が障害なく吹いているような感じで人生が送ることができるんです
ですから その慈悲の瞑想のね
この大変な力によって
皆様方は毎日一生一生幸福でいられますようにという盛大な気持ちがありまして
皆様に幸福をいたします
それから ついでにこの慈悲の瞑想をなさいましたから
まあちょっと理解能力もいくらか高めていると思います
ですから まあそういう前提で
頭が頭が普通よりはかなり今日はね
鋭く鋭く動くだろうという前提でお話をさせていただきます
では こういう風な縁起論ね
縁起といったら 日本語ではね
いろいろ考えちゃいますね
縁起が悪い 縁起がいいという
縁起がいいとかね  その程度のことは考えてますし
で まあだからそれとちょっと違うとは思いますね
無知の無限軌道の切断ポイントなんですが
まあ本当は今日は時間ないんです
この副題のところを説明する
と これは基本的にそれ言わなくちゃいけないんですけど
できる範囲でアクセスしてみようかなと思います
あ また はい まず縁起の始まりということで
まあこの場合 私はあまり定義にはこだわってないんです
まあまあ ただ一般的な縁起と思ってください
縁起ってどこで始めたんだとかね
問題 2つ考えてみます
1つは Why ということ
2番目は How え 当然皆様は縁起
縁起に対する仏典とかいろいろあってもね
そんなに読んで理解できるとは思えないし
ある一つの因果法則 十二因縁ですね
それしか説明してないんです
それでこのそれだけね
無明から行が生じるとかいう
この十二の因果説をは
まあ仏教お坊さんたちにはよく理解できる
仏教の学人にも まあそれなりに理解できないとはないんです
だから ある日 アーナンダ尊者がね
お釈迦様が因果因果法則は難しい
難しい 難しいとよくおっしゃいますけどもね
まあ私にとってはね まあそんなに難しくなくて
まあ普通僕はごく普通シンプルな理論として感じますよと
だからそういう風に言ったんですね
普通だったら これはお前は頭がいいんだからね
しかし 世の中の人間には難しいでしょうと言えばいいのに
まあ時々いますからね
すごい難しい研究勉強がね
軽々とやっている人々がいますから
我々はその場合は あの人はね
特別に頭がいいんですねとかね
天才ですねとかね びっくりとか思ってテレビにも出したりしますね
まあ小学生がこれぐらいの計算はもう誰よりももう計算機よりも早くやっちゃいますよとかね
やっぱりアーナンダ尊者もそういうことに
まあ難しいかもしれませんだけど
私には難しくないんだと言ったところで
お釈迦様があんた何言うのかと
そんな言葉言ってはならんよと
繰り返し 3回言うんです
そんなこと言ってはならんのだと
因果法則こそものすごい難しいんだと
並のものじゃないんだと
人間にはそんな理解できるとは思わないんだと
それは理解できないんだから
我々は人生はぐちゃぐちゃになっちゃって
これにあってもう抜けられなくなって
苦しみから苦しみに回転したりして
もう輪廻転生したり 何やったって悪くの結果がない
この人生が この生命がね
この世に生きているのは
この因果法則ってこの問題解決できないんだからよと
だからどうせ悟りに達している人々はわかっているのは当たり前だからね
だから人間の中で悟っているのは何人ですかね
だから本当に難しいんです
難しいんだからといって
これに挑戦しなくちゃいけないんですよ
逃げるんじゃないんです
なぜかというと この龍樹ナーガルジュナさんがもう大乗仏教の方なんですけど
まあ仏説とは因果法則であると
因果説であると ブッダの教えとは因果の教えであるとも
だから仏教を学ぶということは因果法則を学ぶことになるんですね
彼が決して嘘を言っているわけじゃないんです
仏教の世界ではね 智慧の第一人者として見ているサーリプッタ
シャーリ氏と呼ぶんですね
日本語で お釈迦様の次の智慧のある人なんですね
だから人間として見ると
サーリプッタ尊者ほど智慧の優れた人っていうのはもういない
現れませんし それぐらい智慧のある人が出家する前に
在家でなんか在家生活は嫌なもんやと
もう出家するぞと言って出たところで
もう見栄を張って出家しようと出ましたけどね
何するのかわからないんでね
それからは それである行者に会いましたね
その行者は誰かというと
お釈迦様に最初に最初の説法を聞いて悟りに達した5人比丘の一人なんですね
アッサジという名前の比丘なんですね
それもう阿羅漢なんですね
なんかもうすごい落ち着いている
このアッサジ まあその人は仏弟子だと知らないんですよ
で 見て この人はよっぽど落ち着いているんだと
だから最初に会った人だから
じゃあまあ この人にちょっと話し合ってみて
まあそれから真理を探そうではないかという感じで
まあアッサジ尊者に あなたはどんな教えを信仰して修行しているんですかと
あなたの師匠は何を教えるのかと
言うと アサジ尊者は断るのは相当それは言えませんよと
私はこの道に入ってそんな時間経ってもないし
私の知識能力では説明できないと断るんですね
で 断ってもサーリプッタ尊者はものすごい天才でしたから
え？先生はその困らなくてもいい
要点だけ ポイントだけちょこちょことおっしゃってくれれば
あ それならできますよと言って
ブッダが物事は因縁で生まれるんだよと
因縁で生まれたものは因縁によって消えますよという教えだよと言ったんです
それだけ聞いてよくわかりました
それで結構ですと で 悟りに達するんです
第一段階に 先生 お釈迦様はどこにいらっしゃるんですか？と
場所を教えてください
それで終わったんです
それでお釈迦様に会って出家して
それから仏教の第一人者になるんです
だから そのエピソードのそれは古いエピソード作り話じゃないんです
あの その場合でも 一番最初の五人の弟子の中でも
仏説は因果法則 因縁起であるありということが
まあもう定めてあったんですね
だから 他の宗教と違って
ブッダの教えは何かということがはっきりしているんです
最初の四十五年後でお釈迦様は涅槃に入るで
百年後で作った宗教じゃないんです
最初からもう言ってることははっきりしています
縁起 はい ではこの基本的な縁起はどういうものかと
我々現代人にこれって役に立つ教え？こんな難しいんだったらもうポイントごり押しで教えた方がいいんじゃない？とかね
あるでしょうね それ勉強したら何かいくらか儲かるということもあるしね
何もうからないだったらまあいいや
結構やという で それで新しい仕事でももうね
雇ってくれるならばありがたいんだけどね
まあ縁起法則を理解すればね
もうどんな会社でも雇ってくれますよと言ったならば
誰でも勉強しますよ まあそういうこともないんではないかという気分もあるかもしれません
ですから この我々に本当に役に立つのかという
そういうことを学んで
そういうポイントに中心
焦点合わせて 今日時間ないんだから
できるだけ早いスピードで話そうとしています
ですから このいろいろ本などなどでは皆様には出てこないアイディアが出てくる可能性はあります
はい 一応 Why How ということは知ってますけどね
よく知ってますね でも知らないですか？何？何のことかと
突然 Why と How 出したら
何のことですかね はい
人が認識する 経験するあらゆる現象について
多く少なく なぜ？という疑問が生じるんですね
それでわかるでしょ 私たちはいつでもなぜということは疑問が頭にあるんです
どんなものにしたっても
突然私のもうどこかでずっと痛くなっちゃう
なぜ？なぜということは出てくるんですね
で この質問に見出した答えは
現代まで発展してきた知識
哲学 宗教 科学という結果になっています
このなぜ Why これすごい言葉なんです
その我々の頭の中でなぜという
これが回転しているんだから
人間が哲学を作るんです
科学開発するんです 地球が丸いとも発見したんです
だって海を見ていると昔帆船でしたからね
まずはなんとか高い棒みたいなものを見えてきて
どんどん上からどんどんどんどん下まで
なんでやと 普通だったら船そのまま小さく見えて
どんどんどんどん大きくなって見えた方が普通
経験している知識も視覚範囲はそういうものでしょ
遠くなると小さくなる
近くなってくると大きく見える
あまりにも近くなりすぎちゃうと見えなくなっちゃうとか
でも海の船はそうじゃないんですね
上からどんどんどんどんどんどん下まで見えてくるんです
なんで下の方が隠れているんですかと
だから それなぜということが起きたんだから
はい 誰か誰かがやっぱりこれ丸いんじゃない？ということを発見するんですね
そこで丸いものを描いて
ちょっと漫画を描いてみたら
もうこちらから見ている人になるほど
そういう風に見えるんじゃないかなと
だから私たちもね 結構そこ学校に行く前でもね
そんなことを見たことあるんで
全然謎がやらなかったんですね
そんなもんやと思っちゃうんですね
そんなもんやと思うのもバカなんですね
はっきり言うと なぜということが必要なんです
そのなぜが我々を開発してくれたんです
変えてくれたんです いろんなものを作ってくれたんです
あなたがなんでなんでと
これうるさかった もう煩わしかった時は知識は発展していたんです
その時期あった？覚えがない
ある時ありますよ 小さな子供はうるさいというと
何もなんで なんで なんで
なぜなぜとかね そればっかり連発で機関銃のように撃ちまくるんですね
お母さんに で この間 正月の時
大阪にいましたけども
新幹線で帰る時も もう前の2列目に座ってた人も顔は見えなかったんですけども
まあ小さな子供 男の子がいて
まあなぜばっかし連発で聞いてるんですね
なかなかお父さんにはもうなかなか対応できないし
私は後ろから聞いていると
もうすごく楽しくなっちゃうんですね
あの年っていうのは一番子供の無茶可愛い時なんですね
うるさいんですね 何を聞いても
なぜ？なぜ？これは何？これはなんで
だからここをちょっと頭下げて入ってくださいと
なんでだけど だって頭ぶつけたら痛いんですからと言っちゃっても
で だからなんでと聞いちゃうと
どう答えればいいんですかね
お前危ないこと言うなよと
で 答えでしょ お母さんがダメって言うし
あれダメなんですね あれ
やっぱりなぜには答えなくちゃいけないんで
どうしても答えられない質問されちゃうと
もうこれは答えても君にわかりませんよと
それでも教えて言うでしょ
別に大人の言葉で教えたらいいんです
すると子供はなるほど
なんかわからないことあるみたいですけど
まあそれは頭を空にしましょうということにするんです
あるいははっきりと自分がわからないことで
それはお母さんがわかりませんね
君 大きくなったら学校に行ったら聞いてみてとかね
そういう何とかするんであって
あればダメ押しはしてはいけないんですね
それは知識が開発している時なんです
頭の中でなんでの回数が減るとは
知識の退化を意味します
すごい危険信号なんです
死ぬまで子供のようになぜいっぱいできていると
素晴らしく知恵が開発しっぱなし
なんです ものすごい人生面白くなっちゃうんです
しかし 現実はそうじゃないんですね
なぜは減っちゃうんですね
はい  Why の答えについて
なぜあなたは日本語を話せますか？の Why なら最終的な回答があります
いくつかのなぜには一応答えがあります
しかし 生きるとは何？なぜ人間が現れたのかかなどの Why には決定的な回答はありません
だから なぜといったら答えが見つかる場合もあるし
最終的な答え なかなか答えがはっきりした答えが出ない場合もあります
無数の意見の対立で 異論
争論だけではなく 戦争まで起こるんですね
そういうことで なんで我々はこの世の中にいるのかというと
みんなそれぞれ言うんですよ
猿から進化しましたと
それまたなんでやと それにはそれほどの納得
生きる説明はないんですね
いろいろ化石並べてみて
いろんな動物の形姿並べてみて
一応こんなストーリーではないかなと
ストーリーは作ったんですけど
そもそもなぜ進化するのかという
それには適者生存とかなんとかとかね
適適適応とかね まあいろいろ概念は出されていますし
それも観念ではなくて
それなりにまた調べて調べて
まあ適応するんだと 環境が変化するんだと
だから環境が変化すると生き物が適応しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 変わる環境に適応していったところで
体も変わってしまったという
ような一つの説で しかし
アメリカの 50%以上の人々はそれには大反対なんです
認めません 学校ありますね
もうダーウィンさんの教科書
本を読ましてはいけませんと
そんな嘘一式を教えたらとんでもないことになりますよ
では そういう人々は何言ってるのかというと
これはもう神様がアダムとイブという二人を作りましたから
これまた 1週間で 1週間で神様が作ったことに対して何言うのかと
それにもああそうだという人もいて
それはもうちょっと違うんじゃないかとか言っちゃうと
だったら何万年にそれ言えませんよ
神の言葉は 1週間だからと
ではこういうカラクリしましょうと
神の 1 日と人間の 1 日は同じじゃないんだよと
そうしたらどう？と 神の 1 日っていうのは
100万年程度とかね
だったらどう？する 神が 1週間で言ったって
もうこれ人間が人間の地球の 1週間と考えちゃってね
それ人間が間違ってるんだと
あ それなら納得いきますね
やっぱりダーウィンさんが間違っていると
で また行くんですね それも一つのなぜということには答えなんですね
しかし それはまるっきり認めない
また別々 別々な意見もあるでしょうに
そうなってくるとどうなるかというと
お互いもう異論たくさん世の中で現れちゃうんですね
だから我々人間には仲良くすることは一瞬一向にできませんね
どうしても喧嘩になっちゃうんですね
いくら頑張っても家族は仲良くすることはできないし
会社の仲間は仲良くすることはできないし
もう一緒にいると何かどこかでもう意見違いでもう対立しちゃうんです
毎日なんです 例えば せっかくの日曜日
休日だからと 自分の子供を連れてどこか行ったっても
何回も喧嘩になりますよ
子供と 親が言うことを聞かないで
子供は別なことをやったりして
これやめなさいって 子供はなぜということで
面白いなのにとかね 親から見れば面白いと
これ危ないでしょうと
そこで意見違いですね
これ意見違いでもぶつかったりする
それで子供は自分言うこと聞かないとすぐテロ行為に入りますからね
いきなり泣き出すんですね
ものすごい声で そうするともうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんですね
親も だからその場合でも
小学校にも上がってない自分の子供と一緒に何とか遊びに行こうかなと言ったっても
この意見のぶつかりが起こるんですね
その場合 私は言いたいのは
我々仏教から言えば Why
の問題なんです Why
というなぜということに
自分が出した答えとこの人が出した答えが同じじゃないんです
しかし 論理的に考えると
なぜということにはたくさん答えがあるはずがないんです
何かあるはずなんです
答えが それ見つかってないんだから
こうではないというふうなことになるんです
で 例えばちょこっとしたある地方があるとしましょう
その地方はものすごい雷ばっかり起こる
ものすごい雷が落ちる回数が
昔の人々がそれを見ると
なぜあのところにだけはもうちょっともう雲がかかってきたら
まあドカーンと雷が落ちちゃう
あれは人間が足を踏み入れるべきところじゃないんだと
いつ雷が落ちるかわからないし
で 命がなくなりますからね
そうすると その人々はなぜでしょう？と思うんですね
それで答えを出します
そこは神の陣地で 神の特別な大事なところであって
汚れた人間が入ってはあかん
入ったらもう神がもう雷を落としちゃう
そういうことで そこでみんな納得いって
しかし本当かい？と思っている人々もそこら辺でね
言うこと聞かない連中が
まあちょこちょことそれ行ってみるんですね
言って行っただけで 必ず人間が行くとドカンと雷が落ちるならば
もうしょうがないんですね
人が入ったら雷が落ちる
それだったら誰でも入らない方がいいんだけど
雷が落ちると いくら回数がたくさん落ちる場所だと言っても
行って帰ることはできますよ
そこで一人二人が勇気のある人は行って帰って
おじいちゃん 私は行って帰って行ってきましたよ
あの場所にはと おじさんならすごい怖くなって
なんてことをしたんですか
お前は神に謝りなさいとかね
言うかもしれませんだけど
また時間経つと やっぱり何人か何人かが人々を
あの家の人々は結構行ったりしますよと
ということは その人々にはもう我々よりは何か能力がある人々で
神が特別に許してあげている人々だと
いうふうな話が また出てくると
そうすると神様に特別に許しをもらっている
許可もらっている人々は
当然村で特別な格になってしまったりする
で またそこを子孫の誰かがあちらに行って
雷が当たって死んでしまったら
あの人は何かやったでしょうと
で それでなぜには答えが出ましたね
しっかりと しかし だんだん
例えば現代科学があって
雷はどんな仕組みかとわかったら
なんであの場所はそんなにと
調べたところで山もないし
高いところもないんだけど
雷がかなり落ちると 大体雷が落ちるのは高いところに決まってるしね
で 平らなところだったら
やっぱり何か一つ一本上がってると
そこにはもう雷が入ってきますからね
それは現代のなぜの答えなんですね
それにはあんまり異論がないんですね
どこでも同じ現象が起こるんだから
それでもありますよ 地形的には雷が落ちそうでもないんだけど
バンバン落ちちゃうというところはあるんですね
だからどうしますかね
まだそういうところは研究してないんです
私は知ってる場所はありますよ
ここでなんで雷が落ちるのかとかね
知ってるところは 自分の生まれた田舎のお寺の
あの ちょっと先っぽのところがありまして
そこら辺菩提樹とかありますけど
あの 昔はこの向こう側はもうちょっと高いところあって
もう だからなんでこの高くない低いところにずっと雷が入ってくるのかと
で 来るわ来るわ ちょっと音が出たらもう気をつけた方がいい
そこら辺でずっとあの電気の球がずっと
このあの あの あの あのバードバイト
あの あのフェンスみたいなものあるんだからね
あの あの 時々ありますね
あれは金属鉄ですからね
その中でずっと行ったりするんですね
で なんでこれとね ちょっとなんか理解できない
今は落ちません あの そこら辺そばに
あのでっかい携帯の電波塔がついてます
だから  私はあのお寺のご主人はあんた自然破壊する
よくもこのお寺の土地でね
電波塔を作るってことは認めたもんだなとかね
こんなそばに生活していいわけじゃないんだと
あれこれと言ったって
私は まあそれでもいいんだ
これから雷落ちないでしょうと
はい  例えばそういう雷落ちそうでもないところで
雷の落ちる回数がたくさんあるならば
また村の村人たちはなんとか言うでしょ
こういうわけ こういうわけと
で また他の人はもうそれ違いますよと
だからそれはまた科学的に調べなくちゃいけないしね
で そういうことで ちゃんとした答えを見つけたら
見つかったらもう OK なんです
だから答えあるはずなんです
なぜには それでなんで異論あるのかというと
なぜということに答えがないんだからなんです
それで人間がそんなものやと随分落ち着くんですね
意見たくさんあっていいんじゃない？とかね
本当にそうですかね 意見たくさんあっていいんじゃない？と人に限って対立して喧嘩するんです
私はいろいろ違う意見に対しては全然ニコッと笑うだけなのに
私はやっぱり意見たくさんあっていいとは思ってないんです
人は違う意見を持ったんだからといって何とも思わないんです
それが正しいと思う人々が偉そうなことを言うんだけど
自分の人生で証明しないんですね
自分が人のどんな意見でも
まあもう別に気にしないと寛容的であると
ないんですね 寛容的な人間は
喧嘩するんですね 戦争まで引き起こすんです
仏教の歴史を見てもね
大乗仏教になってから大変ですよ
もう勝手に宗教を作るんだから
これお互い様 結構もう仲良くしない
キリスト教の世界は イスラム教の世界はもっとものすごく怖い
ほんのちょっと違う意見が出てくると
違う意見が出てきたということは
正当の意見には納得いっていない
いってないんだからでしょ
だから正当派の意見に違う意見を出した時点で
もうどちらでもアウトなんです
正しい答えだったら別な意見出せないんです
例えば海ので船がね 上からどんどん下まで見えるのは地球が丸いんだからでしょ
じゃあそれに別な意見出せる？例えば地球は丸い丸いんだからじゃなくて
海のネプチューンでした
海の神様は あれ ネプチューンの神様がわざとそう見えるようにしているんだと
昔からギリシャ時代でも
この神様の何かものを作って船にさせてますから
それ先に見てほしいやと
俺やということで だから上から見えるんだという説は出る
今から今から 言ったっても誰も笑っちゃうでしょ
あんた頭おかしいということで
そういうわけで 正しい答えを見つけたらもう問題はないんです
で あの西洋文化とイスラム教の文化っていうのはずっと殺し合いやっていて
昔からあの で 残酷な殺し合いで
すごい不公平で もうどちらかっていうことは言えないんですね
どちらでもとんでもない悪行為をやっています
で 今 正月ちょこちょこと前で
またなんか飛行機を爆破させようと思ったというね
誰かさんが ちょっと怪しいんだけど
どうやって爆弾爆弾持っていったかとか
ちょっとわからないんだけどね
まあそれはどうでもいい話で
そういうふうなことでよく対立している
お互い殺し合い 殺し合いを殺そうと思っていることだけはありますね
もう疲れちゃって まあ一旦休みましょうと思ったら
誰かがまた刺激するんですね
例えばアフガニスタンで
もう貧しくて貧乏でもうどうしようもないんだから
あの連中が まあ落ち着いてよしたんですね
それでアメリカがそれを取っていったら困りますよと言って
また始めたんでいじめるのは
始めたらまた向こう側もまた始めるんですね
殺し合いは だからまあ
それが現実ですね そのとこまで皆様ご存知だと思いますね
いろんな国々ではもう戦い
戦い 殺し合い 殺し合い
殺し合い テロ行為 あれこれとか
しかし そういう人々は
神はアッラーであって
真理はコーランであり
神はイエホワであって
真理は聖書であると まるっきり二つの違う意見でしょ
それで殺し合ってます
なんでこの連中は地球は丸くないんだよと言って科学者を殺しに行かないんですかね
上は神の世界だからね
宇宙旅行できるわけないんだよと
もう宇宙船に乗ってもぐるぐる回ってくるんだったら
とんでもない神の冒涜だと
これはと で 殺しちゃえばいいでしょうに
片っ端から科学者をやらないでしょ
科学者はセーフなんですね
たとえ宗教 キリスト教であっても
なぜ？なぜと聞いても
なぜにその人は答え出してるんです
それが正解なんですね
そうするともう喧嘩できなくなるんです
という世界なんですね
自分に納得できる答えが出たところで
人は Why を頭から消すんです
これはまた人間の歴史の中で起こる大きな問題
私はこの軽く喋ってますけど
この裏の歴史 ものすごい因果法則が
人類の思考の歴史をまとめて喋っているところなんです
で なんでブッダの場合は因果法則に因果になったのかというと
人間っていうのはなぜということは追求して
とことん調べて最終答えを見つかったわけじゃないんだけど
こうじゃない？という
雷の例で考えれば 盆地なのに雷がボンボン落ちてくる場合は
そこら辺は特別になんか...なんとか何とか霊が憑いてるところじゃない？そういえばそうでしょうねとか
それで納得 それから調べようとしないんですね
だから なんとかちっぽけな答え
考えだった時点で満足して納得しちゃうんですね
それでなぜが頭から消えちゃうんです
それで自分が知っていることは正しいと
と思っちゃうんです ですから
世の中の知識は常に曖昧で問題ばかり作るんです
Why が新たな Why を作るんですね
はい 次のセクション それで我々の人類の歴史を見ると
なぜに適当 適当な答えを見つかるんです
適当な答えを見つかって
それで終わっちゃうんですね
で そこの一つで だから
この適当な答えから出てくる知識は全部曖昧なんですね
盆地になのに雷が落ちるんだ
そちら盆地は聖地と聖地だと言っちゃうと
もう鳥居とかなんとか作って
白いなんかなんかかけておいて
島に縄とかなんとか作って
もうもう大事に そちら立ち入り禁止やと
遠くから採算泣いてもうかしわを売って帰ることになっちゃう
では本当にイルカいるのか？これ曖昧なんですね
今も我々の科学的 学校で大学で学ぶ知識もすべて曖昧でしょ
何一つしっかりした知識がありません
この経営学経済学を学ぶ人々で一番かわいそうなのです
だって実際 我々生きている世界で経済活動を経営しなくちゃあかんだから
もう徹底した曖昧の学問で
どうやって現実的な社会の管理できますかね
お金採算というのは大事なものなんです
うかつに使うもんじゃないんです
人間 いかに感情的で無知であてにならない大馬鹿者やというと
あの官さんが 93 年ぐらいはいいんじゃないと私は思ってますよ
で 勝手に思っちゃえと言いたいんですけど
なんでそれでガクンと
言って終わる瞬間でも
相場がものすごい激しい変動起きちゃって
これはどうしようもない
観相が悪いんだと 悪いのは観相じゃないでしょうに
アホな連中はそういうことをやっていることでしょうに
まるっきり論理性がない
具体性がない 感情で あ
やばい これでやばいとか
現実的な採算が動いているんだから
これ冗談じゃないでしょうに
いきなりもう...もう 30分
30秒で自分の 5億円
6億円が消えちゃったら
数字が もう持ってる財産まで売り売ってしまわなくちゃあかんでしょうに
それぐらい危険が伴ってる世界は
ものの見事にちょっとした感情だけで動いています
それでカンさんは悪人扱いされたりして
カンさんもすごい それはすごい
それなりに勉強している
物事を頑張って学んでいる一人の知識人だから
自分の意見を言ったっても何が悪いんですかね
だから私はあの話を聞きながらね
私なら円台と言いますよと
それでなぜと聞いたら
マスコミが100円計算しやすいんだ
数字は計算がやりやすいでしょ 93
円は だって 150ドル欲しいんだけど
円で150掛ける93だから
もう面倒くさい 100
だったらね 何のこともないですね
150ドル まあ 1万5000円で終わりね
だからまあ私はその話はその程度のものやと思いますよ
しかし この金融世界というのはどんな世界ですかね
で そういうふうなことで
この私は言いたいのは
この曖昧という言葉なんです
世の中でどんな知識にも問題が起きたら当てにならない
医学は学ぶ場合はもうすごい難しくて
すごく頭がいい若者が学校に入らなくちゃいけない
その中でも競争があって
競争ですごい能力ある人だけ進んではいきますけど
ものすごいお金がかかるんですよ
一人の人を育ててもらうためには
いくら腕があれやこれやで
こんな抜群のいい機械が開発されましたが
これはもうこの機械 1台はもう 2億円だよとかね
病院に 2億円の検査機械を入れたっても
もう 1 日患者さんは10人しか調べることはできないんだと
機械の寿命は 5年だから
計算してください 一人の患者さんがどれくらいお金を払えばよろしいかと
はい それではそれぐらいお金を払って検査したら
ビシッと原因見つかって
何のことなく ものの見事に治療して体を治してくれるならば
まあ文句を言ったという必要はないんですね
我慢する それだったらちょっと 10分の検査には 100万円かかったり
まあしょうがない 病気治してくれたんだからと言えるでしょ
しかし治してくれる 曖昧です
命をいじってるのに その世界の知識も曖昧です
知らない 手術はしますけど
それで治ると まあまあ
一応治る可能性はありますと
手術しなかったら しなかったら病気がそのまま悪化してね
まあ終わりますよと 時々
ガンはそのまま放っておいちゃうと
このまま放っておいちゃうと
これはすごい悪性で かなりもう快便も成長してきますよと
これならまあもう半年ぐらいかなとか
あの半年ぐらいっていうのは曖昧な答えなんですね
本当はもう医者から見ればもう 3ヶ月しか持たないだろうという気持ちですけど
やっぱりそれはまずいと言ったらね
だからまあ半年ぐらいでしょうねとか言っちゃうんですね
ちょっと余分に それ曖昧で
そう言われた人も それだったらまあ私は手術やめますと
まあしょうがないと 手術したらどれぐらい？手術したらまあこれこれ取り出しますから
まあまあ 2年  3年は大丈夫やと
それでだったらまあいいやということに決めた人が
もしかするとがんが治る可能性もありますよ
よくわからないんですよ
このがんが自然に消えていくか
あるいはもうどんと成長していくかとかね
そういうことで 我々のすべての知識がもう曖昧
曖昧 曖昧になっているんですね
なんで曖昧になったんですかというと
一つの場合に答えが見つかりますね
見つけたらそれでまあいいや
これで終わった あの納得が問題なんです
これ以上調べません 私はもう世界ももう繰り返すほどのすごいことをもう意見を出しましたとかね
その瞬間でみんなびっくりしますけど
2週間経つとまた別の意見が出てきますからね
別の人からは はい これはもう世の中の現在現在までの状況